[Música]
ae
isso é difícil
[Música]
é isso
ae
op e aí tá escutando agora mano e
assistir o canal turma você e para vejam
só a favor de fazer estatal na
construção aqui em cima tive que acordar
mais cedo que o cara não parece que o
cara chegou já começaram a montar o
domingo total tão gostoso que hoje foi
um dia especial porque a luz ela acordou
e eu fui abraçá ela quando ele estava
com dancinha [__] não queria abraçar seu
cd porque foi o que eu fiz ontem que eu
já assinei nada não fiz ontem eu fiz um
sonho dela ela me disse que a sonhando
ela viu que eu estava olhando muito
diferente com a menina que estava no
fundão e aí eu vi que existe muita
diferença entre você tá namorando e você
está solteiro que quando o cara tá
solteiro ele acolhe não se preocupa com
o que foi que ele fez um sonho a lei
boca na hora não tem que se preocupar
com essas coisas ela vai perguntar o que
foi mo aconteceu no sonho o nome da
menina chefe conhece algum e jéssica e
claro que já se tornou mais comum do
mundo todo mundo conhece a agência todo
mundo conhece mas 15 jesuíno quiquiqui
canta ser nunca para isso aqui é um
trabalho do rio aí sim já está com gelo
e jéssica com j jéssica com com cedilha
jéssica eo jéssica não conhece de hoje
não conhece é um gesto em todo mundo
conhece um gesto pois todo mas só aos 15
já 50 por jaczko jovem que conhece o
projeto eu conheço moisés gesto do teu
sonho e ceagesp é o mesmo para ela já
que os amigos só quer na liga pagar não
quero dar faltando quero dar essa não
conseguiu ouvir muito bem o edital é um
projeto do meu sonho e isso não estava
no sonho não sabe como é que foi não
sabe nada e sigo falando amor ele não tá
rolando páginas que ela que estava
olhando pra mim é um orgulho ter saúde
essa conversa vai a lugar nenhum é muito
diferenciado cartas ou ter contato
namorando uma mulher solteira conca
passou ter muda porque tipo algumas
coisas você tem que se privar querendo o
nosso e se priva acontecer tal
relacionamento falar no celular quando
se fala dos seus amigos quando esses é
solteiro se falava meu amigo por quatro
vezes a filha minha janta fala
verá franciele xingu amigos e ver a
alegria explosão de alegria na boca da
mulher o celular com xingamentos você vê
aquele tom carinhoso e você sabe que
depois daquilo livre um chip ea e
raparigas sabe ele não toca você está
namorando muda falam que quer o ex1
docente whisky aconteceu agora terei
mais ainda a mulher que ela está
solteira é totalmente diferente quando
está namorando e ela está solteira tem
um mundo inteiro para descontar essa tpm
então que acontece dá pra distribuir um
pouquinho cada uma coleta namorada não
quando está namorando ela tem c ó pá e
tá tá tá tá solteiro lá conhecendo carla
reprime essa tpm e on também não ajuda
não tomar e chuto homem deixando uma
pergunta nas costas e evitei o que fui
louco né mas a mulher se contêm que ela
sabe o sinal obrigado receber ktm de uma
vez só tá bem tá tudo bem também de
certeza estou eu também tô achando é
assim o quarto tem nada não nada nada é
cansaço e só quem sabe seja pouca
consegue controlar uma criança tivesse
alterado em razão de tudo com a sérvia
mantém rádio você ande todo mundo tanto
ódio pode queixar da vida no mundo das
coisas aí namorando reduto ódio de que
digo quem é jeff twiss agora eu tô
namorando já passei por pms que eu nunca
pensei com a criatura tão pequena tão
doce tão linda um carinhosa fosse
conseguir fazer um pontapé numa tpm
dança e um dia olha que bacana
ninguém de falar com minha namorada
parece desses pastor que passa de
madrugada na televisão com quem é que eu
estou falando agora acerta né e olha aí
moniz
olha só eu mas como é que é você deixar
da abertura futebol com esse objetivo
hoje quero aqui enfatizar para saber se
conhece alguma chefe que as coisas mudem
a cara tá namorando as coisas mudam de
mais uma vez que a loja foi na minha
casa lá a moça é o toalete apertado a
segunda vez a falar em casa
amor do cabelo porque podíamos e um deus
vivo ou mais pode pegar como ela está
solteira é tudo muito diferente pode
estar namorando a mulher conta solteira
ela escuta jorge mateus papel legenda
vai mudar nas fotos namorando a xuxa
sofreu que sofreu boquiaberta namorando
a menstruação atrasada ave maria acaba
de fotografar fotografado meu disco
também 66 beijar [__] para derrotar
leite meu deus do céu pra falar de si na
casa eu digo não contava matar meu
trabalho para me matar matar a namorada
natália matar todo mundo todo montevidéu
de solteira pode atrasar três meses a
menstruação a fica feliz porque porque
ela não transa a eu tô com três mesma
pontuação em três meses isto é tudo
certo tá grávida não tinha ninguém do
meu velho meu filho é um beijo como é
que ela está solteira ela fica brigando
com a amiga dela não namorar para
arranjar namorado pra não perder a
partir de balada dela até ela começar na
hora aí meu amigo que tem essa minha
filha enfiando machos amigo namorado
dela para essa outra mulher assim a ação
teve início pela mordida na mão e não
vão ficar junta que nós na balada
conhece uma liga seus parceiros vai
pedir paz e começou a namorar e este
começou a namorar a modelo arrumar o
bope e sai de casa ou mesmo pela muito
entender a ligação muda muito quando se
está solteiro coisa tá na hora que o
cara solteiro não terminada e não tem
mundo bem aceito pelo time não tem
nenhum problema em atender nada
landim war no to do nenhum maiô engana
de o neto lhe garanta no golo que dá pra
ver a pessoa antes de atendê se apague
pessoa toque gravando a yoki brasília 9
tal gravando aqui pra galera fazendo
hoje a china mas a gente vai então falou
que chato namorando há ainda uma das
coisas que o catar com os amigos você
fica tem menos alguma coisa foi nada de
errado mas você teme que sua mulher
entenda as coisas errado numa
ae
[Música]
enquanto ann que faz amor chico está
chegando em mim ainda não não dá uma
olhada nas filas porque pensei que achou
eu amo tudo bom
todos aqui com os meninos que só me
ligou mesmo aqui amo tanto meu bebê eu
eu vou pra casa pra casa com um com
daniel com pedro gadget tom outra gente
não conhece a jéssica com essa jéssica
paz não é só resta o meu blog eu vou
falar meu deus tá bom tá bom tom
foi uma conversa militar tinha uma manhã
em que a menina não tinha é bom já é
capaz de dizer que ama aí tem que dizer
que amo o haiti
ana ninguém teve algum aplicativo google
porque é a própria mentira e falar com a
pessoa é olho no olho gordo cards etapa
vem a pessoa a expressão da pessoa
bastante ligado você atender você já viu
uma pessoa táxi que a urgência já tem
novo eu quero você se liga no que sabe o
mundo fez negócio atende a namorada
atingir meu amigo dá pra ver a pessoa
nesse dia que aparece na tela neste
horário que aparece na tela nesse número
que parece na tela por atender chamado
google duas simplesmente olhar cara a
cara de vocês vai ser filmado em tom
baixo app google é só fazer o download
está assim a deixa meu número agendado
lá aí quando foi nesse dia nesse horário
aqui você pode ligar eu vou atender que
já conversar cara a cara eu e você
segundo o baixo logo aplicativo
disponível para android também para o
oeste também é bom já deixa a baixada
que direcionaria nós olho no olho da
cara muito obrigado você assistir esse
vídeo até aqui se você gostasse já sabe
não esquece aplicarem gostei aqui no
youtube você que pode sair sempre gostei
gostei volta lá no facebook você não
estão fazendo isso voltar lá no facebook
ou porque esse vídeo no posto do
facebook que me segue não fez e curtir a
publicação eu quero que você marque lá
no facebook nos comentários seus amigos
que mudam quando não só ter conta
namorando um amigo que virou outra
pessoa ou seja no twitter o que você dê
rt nesse vídeo lá no twitter você dá rt
clique rtp e marcou arroba da sua
amiguinha que muda muito quando começa a
namorar o seu amigo que muda muito
quando começa agora e nós valeu evan e